las masacres horrorizan a colombia en
las últimas 24 horas el país padeció
tres que se suman a las 33 que ha habido
durante todo el año según la oficina de
la alta comisionada del agua
la cifra preocupa si se tiene en cuenta
que en todo 2019 hubo 36 en los
departamentos de nariño cauca y arauca
donde ocurrieron las últimas masacres
convergen la ausencia del estado altos
índices de pobreza y una gran cantidad
de desplazados esta seguidilla de
matanzas ha generado repudio en la
sociedad colombiana e incluso marchas en
medio de la pandemia para rechazar lo
que consideran una falta de respuesta o
una respuesta lenta por parte del estado
el presidente iván duque visitó los
lugares donde ocurrieron las dos
primeras mientras que el ministerio de
defensa anunció una unidad especial para
lo que el gobierno denomina homicidios
colectivos hemos visto homicidios
colectivos en otros lugares del
territorio y yo quiero también decir con
mucha claridad que estos hechos
dolorosos desafortunadamente
no han desaparecido en nuestro país
aunque aún se desconoce quiénes
perpetraron las masacres tras el proceso
de paz con la ex guerrilla de las farc
el conflicto armado ese fragmento más
hay disidencias de esta antigua
guerrilla frentes del ejército de
liberación nacional
ln grupos paramilitares como las
autodefensas gaitanistas y otros más
pequeños de bandas criminales
estos grupos se concentran
principalmente en lugares que coinciden
con la expansión de cultivos de coca
aunque no está establecida la conexión
entre las masacres con el narcotráfico o
los grupos armados